-Our first guest tonight is an
Academy Award-winning actres
you know from films like
"Black Swan," "Jackie,"
and the "Star Wars" prequels
Her new children's book,
there it is right here,
"Natalie Portman's Fables,
is available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
Natalie Portman.
Hi, Natalie, how are you?
-Hi, I'm good.
I'm so glad to talk to you
-It's wonderful to talk
to you now as well.
And I should notice our nows
are very different,
because you are in Australia
It is very early for you, yes?
-Yeah, it's like 7:30,
so it's not super early.
Normal parent early.
-Yes.
I guess that's the thing,
that once you become a parent,
you realize you have
a different sliding scale
for what being early is.
And I should use that as
transition to talk about
your book, which is great
that you decided to write one.
What have you changed abou
these sort of three
existing fables?
-Well, I realized when I was
reading to my kids --
I have a 9-year-old son an
a 3 1/2-year-old daughter.
And when I started reading
to my daughter, I realized
so many of the classic books
have almost all
male protagonists.
And so, I started changing
the pronouns.
And then I was like, "This jus
needs to be different."
So I was like, "we don't need to
throw away the old stories
I just want to have them
with a character populatio
that reflects the world more."
So, I set out to rewrite three
of -- three of my favorites.
-So I've got --
I have two boys.
They're 4 1/2, 2 1/2.
And I'm wondering,
did your kids then have
different favorite books
because their genders
were different,
or did they like the same thing?
-They really liked both --
they really both liked
the same things,
which was a really nice thin
to see.
But then I realized that
a lot of the kind of
feminist-skewing books
were geared towards girls,
and none of them became
her favorites.
But my son wasn't even exposed
to them in terms of, like,
people giving presents or th
kinds of things, you know,
they aim at him.
So I was like, "Oh, we nee
the classic things,
the things that all kids read,
to have just a real
reflection of the world."
-I would imagine the scaries
thing about writing
a children's book would be you
own children's reaction to it.
How have they responded so far
-Yeah, no, they're my toughest
critics, by far.
Like, they are constantly
cutting me down and telling me
you know --
[ Laughter ]
I'm inadequate in whatever way
So they were kind of the best,
most honest editors,
like throughout.
I would just read it to them
and you could tell
when they were bored
or losing attention
or, you know, didn't
get something.
So, it was great to be able to
like, change it
and test it out on them,
and see what I could do
to make them laugh.
-Have they -- are there othe
sort of bodies of your wor
that they've watched?
Have they watched any
of your movies?
-No, they haven't.
I think it's weird for the
to see you in, like, a different
context than their mom.
-Sure.
-Like, until they're older
and they can kind of
conceptually get it better
Do your kids watch you, ever
-No, I mean, they've seen me
on -- you know where they
see me, is on Taxi TV.
-Oh.
-'Cause every now and then
there will be a clip
of the show.
-And they don't --
-That's major.
You've really made it.
-Yeah, they really --
I mean, for a kid, if you ca
show up in any sort of
mode of transportation,
they kind of lose their minds.
-That's super cool.
-Yeah, but they then --
they sort of recognize me, and
then they want me to mute it
Whereas I tell them, "Look
the only way it's even possibl
for the taxi driver
to know who's in the car
is if we turn the volume u
way high."
[ Laughter ]
You're actually -- I hope
I'm right here,
you're in Australia working on
the new "Thor" movie,
is that correct?
-Yes, yes.
We haven't started filming yet
We're just prepping.
-And this is with --
Taika is the director.
He's such a fantastic director
I think now it obviously
makes perfect sense,
but maybe it was a little
unlikely in the beginning
to direct a big superhero
franchise like this.
Is it exciting to work with him?
-It's so awesome.
He's just got, like,
the best spirit.
He's so -- he's like
a very good person,
and he's also hilarious.
And the combination is very,
very endearing.
So, it's very exciting to ge
to go to work and, like,
laugh a lot there.
-I know that there's no movi
that's more under wraps than
a Marvel movie,
but there is rumors, at least,
that you might be wielding
the hammer.
That's pretty exciting.
-Yeah, yeah, no.
I mean, we've -- we've
definitely been able
to talk about and openly
talked about the fact
that Jane becomes
the Mighty Thor,
like in some of
the graphic novels.
So it's pretty -- pretty
exciting to get my superhero on.
-It's been long overdue.
Something else that's really
exciting and ties into
I think a lot of what we'r
talking about is you were
announced as one of
the owners of a new
professional women's
soccer team.
Here's a picture of you
with Megan Rapinoe.
She's one of our favorites her
as well.
How did you get involved wit
being one of the owners
of this new team?
-Well, with Time's Up,
it was kind of the first tim
that women across industries
had gotten together.
So women in tech, and business
and sports, and film,
and medicine, advertising,
all these different
kind of backgrounds
came together.
And when we started hearing from
some of the athletes,
particularly the one
that really inspired me
was listening to Abby Wambach to
talk about her experience.
And, to think these best players
in the world,
in the world's most
popular sport,
weren't being given
the kind of recognition,
amplification, you know,
compensation,
that they deserved
was really crazy.
So a group of us got togethe
and said,
"Okay, we're going to try
and take this differently.
And so it's the first women-led,
women-investor
professional sport team.
And we're Angel City FC,
and we'll be starting in 2022.
We're just going into player
recruitment and all of that.
-Did you play soccer
in high school?
-Oh, no. I'm like the leas
athletic person of all time.
Maybe that's why I admire it
so much.
-Right.
-But that's why --
Everyone who knows me is like,
"How did you end up in this?
But I'm a big -- I'm a big fan
I really admire it.
And I could not, like, dribble
a ball to save my life.
-It should be noted that I think
when you look at owners
of male sports, you never think,
"Oh, I bet they'd be
really good at football."
-Right.
-So, I think it's very natural
to maybe not be someone who ha
to go out on the field as well
-Exactly.
It's like kind of part of bein
a fan is they're, like,
kind of, you know,
stand-ins for what you
wish you could do.
-Absolutely.
You mentioned Time's Up.
I know you've been really
involved not only with that,
but very vocal politically
You know, it's a very
strange time to talk,
because obviously we're,
you know, a week out
from an election.
There are maybe reasons
to be optimistic
as well as reasons to
be deeply pessimistic.
How are you -- what is you
emotional state right now?
-Uh, I'm --
I think I'm on edge,
as most people are, about
what is going to happen.
Because it feels like it wil
really determine
the future in a big way
for our kids.
But I am -- what makes me
optimistic
is how engaged
people have become.
Like, I figure people care mor
than they ever have
in my lifetime
for sure about politics
and what's happening
and being personally involve
and personally invested
and realizing that
their votes make a difference.
And so, that's been kind of th
silver lining, I think,
to all of this,
is that everyone is really
kind of feeling like
they're part of this,
and they need to be active
-I guess 3 is probably
too young to be aware.
But is your -- how aware
is your 9-year-old
of everything that's happening
-Oh, so aware.
I mean, the -- both my kid
are aware.
I mean, my 3-year-old
obviously less so,
but she'll say -- she'll tal
about Trump and Biden,
like in conversation.
I think she hears it so much
And my son is very aware and
talks about it with his friends.
And he really realized how muc
it's impacted them.
Like, they've grown up largely
under this presidency.
And it's really a different --
I mean, my daughter completely
of course,
but my son, half his life ha
been under this presidency
And so it's quite --
quite remarkable
how much these young peopl
are engaged and curious.
-It is interesting how
they're -- it's pretty easy,
I feel like, to explain
the current President
to kids, because he is lik
a fable in a lot of ways.
Like, if they read one or tw
children's books, you're like,
"Here's where he fits in."
-Yeah.
And you try not to, like -
I try not to --
I always want my kids to hav
nuance and never be like,
"Oh, this person is bad --
-Of course.
-Or "This person is good,"
and be like,
"You know, people are
complicated."
But it's comp-- it's hard to get
that across with Trump.
I'm like -- I don't want t
like demonize,
but like, I might just
demonize him, you know?
-We had the best --
-Yeah, it's hard to find
the nuance.
-We had the best thing in th
world happen the other day
which is my sister-in-law,
her name is Ariel,
and she's very close
with my wife,
and we love her very much,
but we were talking
about Donald Trump
to our 4-year-old,
and one of the things we sai
is, "He's very rude."
And he took that in and he said,
"But not as rude as Ariel,
right?"
And I was like, "Oh, this is..
[ Laughter ]
...literally the greatest --
And just to be able to say
to him, like, "No, he's not.
[ Laughter ]
He's not like that."
-That's great.
-Hey, it's always so wonderful
to see you.
I can't wait to read the boo
to my kids.
And be well over there.
-Thank you. You too.